في مكالمته مع نتنياهو الرئيس بايدن يقول
ان انه تحدث عن فكره حل الدولتين مع
نتنياهو وان الاخير لم يعارض لم يقل
البيان ان نتنياهو
يوافق ما
رايك هي هذه النقطه الاساسيه انه لم يقل
انه يوافق انما لم يعارض طبعا لم نسمع من
نتنياهو بعد لكن سمعنا منه يوم الخميس
بالنسبه لنا يوم امس بالنسبه لكم يوم اول
امس سمعنا من نتنياهو خطابا واضحا ورسميا
يعني كان يوجه خطابه للامريكيين ويقول انه
لن يقبل بدوله فلسطينيه لن يعيد الخطا
الذي ارتكب في عام 93 عبر توق بتوقيع
اتفاق اوسلو وبانه لن يكون هناك السياده
وهذه نقطه اساسيه غرب غربيه نهر الاردن
الا لاسرائيل فاذا الاشكال هنا انه لا
يوجد حديث عن الدوله الفلسطينيه انما يتم
الحديث عن عدم معارضه نتنيا اه دون ان
نتاكد ان هذا الكلام صحيح اصلا القضيه هنا
اننا نتحدث عن عن رجلان في ازمه نتحدث عن
بايدن الذي لديه ازمه كبيره لا يستطيع ان
يضغط على الجانب الاسرائيلي هو يشعر
باحباط كبير من نتنياهو شخصيا وهذه تقارير
مؤكده الان نشرت يعني في عده مصادر اليوم
حتى كثير من المسؤولين الامريكيين يقولون
هذا الكلام لعدد من وسائل الاعلام ان هناك
شعور بالاحباط لدى بايدن شخصيا من نتنياهو
لانه استثمر فيه سياسيا وظن ان اقترابه
منه بعد هجوم السابع من اكتوبر انه سيكون
ميزه وراس مال سياسي له معه اليوم يكتشف
انه لا يملك ذلك راس المال السياسي هذا
وايضا يكتشف ان نتنياهو على استعداد ان
يضحي بمصالح بايدن الانتخابيه وهذا كلام
لمسؤولين امريكيين ليس ان نتنياهو على
استعداد ان يضحي بمصالح اسرائيل فقط كما
يقولون هنا وفي اسرائيل بل عنده استعداد
ان يضحي بمصالح امريكا وبما في ذلك مصالح
بايدن الانتخابيه بالنسبه لنتنياهو
نتنياهو ايضا بعيدا عن قناعاته
الايديولوجيه التي نعرفها عنه منذ سنوات
طويله هو ايضا محكوم في توازنات حكوميه في
توازن
ائتلافي صعبه جدا ومن ثم حتى لو اراد حتى
لو اراد ان يتوافق مع الامريكيين من زاويه
المسايره فانه لي لا يملك هذه لا يملك هذا
الخيار لان من حوله في الائتلاف الحكومي
سيدفعون ه ثمنا سياسيا كب يران فاذا لا هي
تعبير عن ازمه لدى طرفين واظن ان بايدن
يبحث عن اي طريقه يخفف الضغوط التي تمارس
عليه سواء من داخل حزبه سواء في الكونجرس
ام من القاعده الانتخابيه ومن ثم لم يقل
انه وافق لكنه قال انه لم يبدي انهاء
الصراع يقتضي انهاء الاحتلال وفكره انهاء
الاحتلال كما تطرقت انت مرفوضه يعني من
جانب اليمين المتطرف الذي يدعم يدعم
بنيامين نتنياهو الامر معقد في داخل
اسرائيل على المستوى السياسي وطوال سنوات
لم يتمكن بايدن من يعني فك هذه المغاليق
مع مع نتنياهو وشهدت وشهدنا عده خلافات في
السنوات الاخيره هل من من المنطقي ان ان
يتمكن بالفعل بايدن في ما تبقى له من
اشهر من من فعل
ذلك لا من غير المنطقي اصلا وبمناسبه يعني
حتى اداره بايدن وسواء بلينكن او سولفن
ممن تحدثوا عن ضروره ان يكون هناك حل
دولتين تحدثوا عنه في الصياغ الاقليمي في
السياق الاقليمي ولم يتحدثوا عنه في
السياق الفلسطيني الاسرائيلي المباشر هذه
من زاويه الزاويه الثانيه انهم لم يتكلموا
عن نشوء دوله خلال الفتره الرئاسيه ل
لبايدن او على الاقل الفتره الرئاسيه
الحاليه انما قالوا ان هذه مساله صعبه لكن
نريد افقا افقا سياسيا لامكانيه قيام دوله
فلسطينيه لكن هناك مشاكل في قبل ذلك
اسرائيل لازالت لا لا زالت لا تقبل اصلا
بان يكون هناك توحيد لشطر الضفه وقطاع غزه
تحت سلطه فلسطينيه مطوره هذا هذه السلطه
الفلسطينيه المطوره لن يكون فيها محمود
عباس رئيسا حسب ال الخطه التي طرحها
مروورك الذي طرحت بريت مغرك الذي طرحت
وقال فيها انه لن يكون محمود عباس رئيسا
انما سيتم هندسه الرئاسه الفلسطينيه كما
هندس القياده الفلسطينيه في عام 2003 2004
2002 2003 ثم كان مجيء محمود عباس رئيسا
في اواخر في عام 2005 فاذا هناك حديث حتى
هذه الهندسه لا يقبل بها نتنياهو رغم ان
هناك توافق اسرائيلي امريكي على الاقل اذا
تحدثنا عن المؤسسات الامنيه والعسكريه
الاسرائيليه التي تقول ان السلطه
الفلسطينيه تؤدي دورها حسب الاتفاقيات
خصوصا فيما يتعلق بالبعد الامني ومن ثم
حتى هذه السلطه حتى شخص الرئيس الفلسطيني
محمود عباس الذي معروف موقفه من المقاومه
المسلحه حتى المقاومه الشعبيه لا يريد
ومع ذلك حتى هذا الشخص مع تطوير السلطه
بحيث تكون اقرب لاسرائيل حتى هذه الصيغه
مرفوضه بالنسبه لاسرائيل ونتنياهو فكيف
اذا يمكن الحديث عن دوله فلسطينيه اذا ما
يعني بعد سنوات من الان ثم لنتذكر هي
المساله ليست مرتبطه بالليو والتيار
اليميني والمتطرفين نحن نتحدث عن فشل
حكومات متعاقبه اسرائيليه بما فيها حكومات
من حزب العمل سواء عندما كان بيريز رئيسا
للوزراء في منتصف التسعينيات او عندما جاء
ايهود بارك رئيسا للوزراء وعندما جاء
الوسط عبر ايهود اولمرت كل هذا كل هذه
الحكومات لم تنجح في الوصول الى اتفاق مع
الفلسطينيين على دوله فلسطينيه لانه هناك
معارضه اسرائيليه داخليه هنا البنيه
السياسيه الاسرائيليه لا تستطيع ان ترى
دوله فلسطينيه حتى عبر التنازلات التي
قدمت يعني وكلنا يذكر وثائق الجزيره التي
كشفت في عام 2010 عن المستوى الذي ذهبت
اليه السلطه الفلسطينيه في تقديم التنازل
حتى في القدس حتى في مساله اللاجئين التي
اختزلت الى 5000 لاجئ يعودون على مدى خمس
سنوات وليس مره واحده كل هذه ال التنازلات
الفلسطينيه لم يقبلها الجانب الاسرائيلي
فاذا عندما يتحدث بايدن هنا هو يتحدث في
سياق التمنيات وفي
سياق في سياق محاوله شراء الوقت مع قاعدته
الانتخابيه لانه يواجه ازمه كبيره لا
يستطيع ان يبقى يستفز قاعدته الانتخابيه
ونحن نقر من الانتخابات العامه وفي نفس
الوقت لا يريد ان يستفز اللوبي الصهيوني
وان يستفز كبار المتبرعين المحسوبين على
اللوبي الصهيوني بما في ذلك اليهود
الامريكيين